c'est je suis content j'ai décroché la
faire enfin quand je dis je j'exagère
mon agence de publicité publique
pour resituer c'est nous qui avons lancé
les semelles cryptex et l'année d'après
les creps melix mais là sur ce coup-ci
attention n'était pas tout seul vous
pensé dit une campagne électorale
il y avait tout le monde ils y étaient
tous il y avait havas et publicis
il y avait l'autre la caf et la campagne
de mitterrand
c'est pas dire son nom parce que j'ai
pas faire de la réclame à la conférence
résultat des courses c'est moi qui les
coache à tes balles allaient rouler
alors le président à sanaa je peux pas
vous le dire parce que justement
première chose je vais le faire changer
de nom ils t'ont marqué depuis 25 ans il
est passé de gauche à droite de droite à
gauche au centre à droite à gauche
c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas des bons
documents sur lui sur toutes les photos
il bouge mon idée très branché très
ouais c'est d'essayer de trouver un nom
et si les familles sont d'essayer de
racheter un an oui
achetez pas trouver acheter pendant que
marie christine barrault aurait pété là
moi j'étais dans la coulisse attend que
ce soit mon tour pour m'amuser père
c'est complètement moi je tiens tout ça
à l'arrêt du coup il allume la lumière
là j'arrête mon jetage vous allume la
lumière avant c'est fini en coupe matin
c'est ça la vie oui j'ai eu un trou de
mémoire quoi et alors on est à
l'intelligence
mon idée très branché boyer c'est
d'essayer de racheter un nom oui si les
familles sont d'accord dont le
propriétaire d'origine est mort mais
dans le nom garde encore un crédit
énorme sur le puits voyez laval
blum
franco choses comme ça pas vous achetez
de la fine napoléon
l'argent ne va plus dans la poche de
napoléon c'est un point que pdg
car pilonnant et quand un homme
merveilleux
comme j'ai paul ricard va passer la main
ça sera plus lui mais son nom servira de
caution pour beurrer des générations et
des générations
oui enfin en attendant et du travail
vient du travail le regard à télévision
on change rien comme il me dit vous
m'apportez votre pragmatisme
je vous apporte mon strabisme la france
au fond des yeux ça n'a pas marché lui
la regarde un côté d'une au sud-ouest au
mot les travaux très bien rien dire mais
son élocution
ils votent et pas comme ça mais l'autre
jour j'ai réglé je fais j'aime et en
uefa devant 2000 personnes là le sonn la
scission au sein de l'opposition
opposition de ne pas fait
arrête je meurs je vais chanter toutes
les dates comme je vais mettre que des
dents en or pour rassurer les épargnants
sans accepter les riches j'ai demandé
aussi de changer de femme
il veut pas elle m'énerve elle elle
m'énerve elles pensent comme venus elle
dit alors quand on recevra la visite de
monsieur ronald reagan
tu fais une pige maalot à la grenobloise
qu'est ce que je pourrais lui faire dire
à mes nerfs elle sur les habits et la
coiffure je la ridiculise cela grotesque
achevé la kalina valises
je vais fait changer la couleur de ses
cheveux pendant que d'une couleur je
vous dis pas c'est pas ta qui commencent
ou les affiches réponse absente
parce que mon fils de la fiche c'est
vous avez un village typiquement
français le ciel derrière et devant au
premier plat personnes non maudit et à
la place on écrit en grosses lettres
majuscules lui il est déjà au travail
quand je vais au président quand même qu
est ce qu on dit dans les slogans que
vous êtes de gauche de droite je
m'excuse gilles guimond si je m'excuse
roland si je le dis je perd
automatiquement 50% des voix
attention le professionnel rom est
difficile a dit oui oui c'est là que
franchement j'étais génial d'ailleurs il
m'a téléphoné après il m'a dit
heureusement je vous embrasse vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir remarquer que la
droite dit partout que la gauche
accumule les maladresses ne vous dit
rien vous allez en termes de sogreah à
partir de lundi ils sont tous des radios
c'est sa voix à le liquider
votez pour moi pour une gauche à droite